but you know you were just starting to
to talk a little bit about what you know
we talked about you know space
that represents all the stuff that's in
the universe
the question is what does that stuff do
and
for that we have to start talking about
time and what is time
and so on and you know one of the the
basic
idea of this model is time is the
progression of computation
so in other words we have a a structure
of space and
there is a rule that says how that
structure of space will change
and it's the application the repeated
application of that rule
that defines the progress of time
um and what does the rule look like the
in a space of hyper grass
right so what the rule says is something
like if you have a little tiny piece of
hypograph that looks like this
then it will be transformed into a piece
of hypergraph that looks like this
so that's all it says it says you pick
up these elements of space
and the you can think of these these uh
edges these hyper edges as being
relations between elements in space
you might pick up uh these two relations
between elements in space
and we're not saying where those
elements are or what they are but every
time there's a certain
arrangement of elements in space then
arrangement in the sense of the way
they're connected
then we transform it into some other
arrangement so there's a little tiny
pattern and you transform it into
another little pattern
that's right and then because of this i
mean again it's kind of similar to
cellular automata in that like
yes on paper the rule looks like super
simple it's like
uh yeah okay yeah the
yeah right from this the universe can be
born uh but like
once you start applying it beautiful
structure starts
being potentially can be created and
what you're doing is you're applying
that rule
to different parts like any time you
match it within the hyper graph exactly
and then one of the
like incredibly beautiful and
interesting
things to think about is the order in
which
you apply that rule yes because that
pattern appears all over the place
right so this is a big complicated thing
very hard to wrap one's brain around
okay so
so you you say the rule is every time
you see this little pattern
transform it in this way but yet
you know as you look around the space
that represents the universe
there may be zillions of places where
that little pattern occurs
so so what what what it says is just
do this apply this rule wherever you
feel like and
what what is extremely non-trivial is
well okay so so this is happening sort
of in in computer science terms sort of
asynchronously you're just doing it
wherever
wherever you feel like doing it and the
only constraint is that if you're going
to apply the rule somewhere
the the things to which you apply the
rule the little
you know elements to which you apply the
rule if
they if they have to be
okay well you can think of each
application of the rule as being kind of
an event
that happens in the universe and these
the input to an event has to be ready
for the event to occur that is if one
event occurred if one transformation
occurred
and it produced a particular atom of
space then
that atom of space has to already exist
before another transformation that's
going to apply to that atom of space can
occur so yeah so that's like the
prerequisite for the event
that's really existing that's right so
it that defines
a kind of uh this sort of set of causal
relationships between events it says
this event happens it has to have
happened before this event
but that is um but that's that's not a
very limiting constraint
no it's not um you still get the zillion
uh that's the technical term options
that's correct
you